hannover
schön dich wiederzusehen ich habe lange
nichts von dir gehört wie ist es dir
ergangen hanomag schön dich
wiederzusehen
ich habe lange nichts von dir gehört wie
ist es dir ergangen
hallo kerstin schön dich wiederzusehen
wir haben lange nicht mehr miteinander
gesprochen
hallo kerstin schön dich wiederzusehen
wir haben lange nicht mehr miteinander
gesprochen
mir geht es gut ich arbeite in einer
bank im administrativen bereich
ich bin jetzt seit zwei jahren dort
mir geht es gut ich arbeite in einer
bank im administrativen bereich
ich bin jetzt seit zwei jahren dort
meiner familie geht es auch sehr gut sie
sendet dir viele grüße meiner familie
geht es auch sehr gut sie sendet dir
viele grüße schön das zu hören
schön das zu hören guten tag
entschuldigen sie was möchten sie
trinken
guten tag entschuldigen sie
was möchten sie trinken guten tag wir
möchten bitte zwei bier bestellen danke
guten tag wir möchten bitte zwei bier
bestellen danke sicher mit vergnügen
sicher mit vergnügen
und wie geht es dir
ich habe gehört dass du in einem anderen
land warst erzählen mir davon
und wie geht es dir ich habe gehört dass
du in einem anderen land warst erzählen
mir davon
mir geht es auch sehr gut mir geht es
auch sehr gut
auch meine familie sendet die viele
grüße auch meine familie sendet dir
viele grüße meine eltern sind
mittlerweile pensioniert
und beschäftigen sich mit verschiedenen
arbeiten am haus
meine eltern sind mittlerweile
pensioniert
und beschäftigen sich mit verschiedenen
arbeiten am haus
und meine schwester hat ihr studium der
betriebswirtschaft abgeschlossen und
angefangen in einem unternehmen zu
arbeiten und meine schwester hat ihr
studium der betriebswirtschaft
abgeschlossen und angefangen in einem
unternehmen zu arbeiten
verzeihung hier ist ihr bier verzeihung
hier ist ihr bier
ich danke ihnen ich danke ihnen
ich bin froh dass es allen gut geht
ich bin froh dass es allen gut geht und
wie du weißt bin ich gerade von einer
reise nach südafrika zurückgekommen
genauer gesagt aus johannesburg ja und
wie du weißt bin ich gerade von einer
reise nach südafrika zurückgekommen
genauer gesagt aus johannesburg wow das
klingt super interessant erzähl mir mehr
wow das klingt super interessant
erzählen mir mehr
ja die erfahrung war sehr interessant
ich war dort als freiwillige in einem
naturpark tätig ja die erfahrung war
sehr interessant ich war dort als
freiwillige in einem naturpark tätig du
weißt dass ich tiere schon immer geliebt
habe und dies war die perfekte
gelegenheit das zu tun was ich liebe und
zu reisen um neue kulturen kennen zu
lernen
du weißt dass ich tiere schon immer
geliebt habe und dies war die perfekte
gelegenheit das zu tun was ich liebe und
zu reisen um neue kulturen kennen zu
lernen
ich war in einem naturschutzgebiet so
verschiedene tierarten geschützt wurden
ich war in einem naturschutzgebiet wo
das projekt an dem ich gearbeitet habe
hatte zwei schwerpunkte der erste war
der naturschutz und die überwachung von
wildtieren
das projekt an dem ich gearbeitet habe
hatte zwei schwerpunkte der erste war
der naturschutz und die überwachung von
wildtieren
ein riesenprojekt habe ich relevante
informationen über löwen leoparden
elefanten hyänen und nashörner gesammelt
in diesem projekt habe ich relevante
informationen über löwen leoparden
elefanten hyänen und nashörner gesammelt
und das zweite projekt war die arbeit
zur förderung von anti wilderer
aktivitäten kerstin das klingt gut
kerstin das klingt gut ich kann mir
vorstellen dass du eine menge gelernt
hast
ich kann mir vorstellen dass du eine
menge gelernt hast ja mag ich dort war
hatte ich die gelegenheit die tiere in
ihrem lebensraum zu sehen und es war
wirklich magisch ja mag
als ich dort war hatte ich die
gelegenheit die tiere in ihrem
lebensraum zu sehen und es war wirklich
magisch ich habe die bewegungen das
verhalten und die ökologischen
auswirkungen der arten verfolgt und
aufgezeichnet
ich habe die bewegungen das verhalten
und die ökologischen auswirkungen der
arten verfolgt und aufgezeichnet
ich habe viel gelernt und es war eine
sehr interessante erfahrung
und was waren die voraussetzungen für
die freiwilligenarbeit und was waren die
voraussetzungen für die
freiwilligenarbeit man muss ein
besonderes interesse an der
tierschutzarbeit in der wildnis und
englischkenntnisse auf mindestens wie
ego haben
man muss ein besonderes interesse an der
tierschutzarbeit in der wildnis und
englischkenntnisse auf ungesundes niveau
haben und man muss bedenken dass viele
dinge auf der reise von der organisation
nicht abgedeckt werden und man muss
bedenken dass viele dinge auf der reise
von der organisation nicht abgedeckt
werden das mindestalter für die
teilnahme ist 18 jahre
das mindestalter für die teilnahme ist
18 jahre
na ja da war es gar nicht so kompliziert
da rein zu kommen das ist gut
da rein zu kommen das ist gut die
arbeitszeit wurde auf zwei
überwachungsschiffe pro tag aufgeteilt
die arbeitszeit wurde auf zwei
die morgenschicht ging um 35 los und die
nachmittagsschicht um 15 uhr
ich hatte zwei tage pro woche frei
ich hatte zwei tage pro woche frei wow
diese freiwilligen arbeit war ziemlich
fordernd
wow diese freiwilligen arbeit war
ziemlich fordernd ja zu meinen aufgaben
gehörten das verfolgen und fotografieren
der tiere zum garten über löwen
spitzmaulnashörner elefanten und
leoparden zu sammeln
ja zu meinen aufgaben gehörten das
verfolgen und fotografieren der tiere um
daten über lügen spitzmaulnashörner
elefanten vielen und leoparden zu
sammeln
ich beobachtete die tiere und zeichnete
daten über ihr verhalten ihre bewegungen
ihren standort und ihre
fressgewohnheiten auf ich habe auch beim
aufstellen der kamera fallen geholfen
ich habe auch beim aufstellen der kamera
fallen geholfen
ich reiste in weniger besuchte teile des
parks in weniger bekannte tiere zu
identifizieren und zu verfolgen
ich reiste in weniger besuchte teile des
parks um weniger bekannte tiere zu
identifizieren und zu verfolgen
ich sollte die wälder und restaurierte
straßen und entfernte exotische pflanzen
dies trug dazu bei das ökosystem im
gleichgewicht zu halten und gab den
tieren eine bessere lebensqualität dies
trug dazu bei das ökosystem im
gleichgewicht zu halten und gab den
tieren eine bessere lebensqualität und
ich habe die tiere kann strategischen
kunden aus beobachtet damit sie von will
daran nicht getötet wurden
und ich habe die tiere von strategischen
kunden aus beobachtet damit sie von will
daran nicht getötet wurden und wie lange
dauert so eine freiwilligenarbeit
und wie lange dauert so eine
freiwilligenarbeit die mindestdauer
beträgt zwei wochen und die höchstdauer
zwölf wochen
die mindestdauer beträgt zwei wochen und
die höchstdauer zwölf wochen
ich habe es vier wochen lang gemacht ich
habe es vier wochen lang gemacht und hat
es etwas gekostet sich freiwillig zu
melden und hat es etwas gekostet sich
freiwillig zu melden
nein es ist völlig kostenlos
als gegenleistung erhält man unterkunft
und verpflegung nein es ist völlig
kostenlos
als gegenleistung erhält man unterkunft
und verpflegung die kosten für das
ticket die für die reise notwendigen
impfungen und gegebenenfalls das visum
werden von der organisation nicht
übernommen die kosten für das ticket die
für die reise notwendigen impfungen und
gegebenenfalls das visum werden von der
organisation nicht übernommen
sehr gut erzählen mir von der kultur den
menschen und dem essen
menschen und dem essen die menschen
waren sehr herzlich und freundlich
die menschen waren sehr herzlich und
freundlich das essen war köstlich ich
glaube ich habe während meiner reise
zugenommen aber ich habe es mit all der
arbeit die ich geleistet habe wieder
wettgemacht das essen war köstlich
ich glaube ich habe während meiner reise
zugenommen aber ich habe es mit all der
arbeit die ich geleistet habe wieder
wettgemacht
als ich dort war habe ich bill tom
probiert das einem beef jerky ähnlich
ist
als ich dort war habe ich bill tom
probiert das einem beef jerky ähnlich
ist
ich habe auch straußenfleisch gegessen
es war wirklich köstlich ich habe auch
straußenfleisch gegessen
es war wirklich köstlich und wie hat das
straußenfleisch geschmeckt und wie hat
das straußenfleisch geschmeckt es war
etwas süßer und hatte etwas weniger fett
und cholesterin aber im aussehen war es
ähnlich wie rindfleisch
es war etwas süßer und hatte etwas
weniger fett und cholesterin aber im
aussehen war es ähnlich er im fleisch
ich habe auch bobby probiert ein gericht
das seinen ursprung in der malaysischen
küche hat es war wie ein hackbraten mit
rosinen und einem gekochten oben drauf
ich habe auch bo body probiert
ein gericht das seinen ursprung in der
malaysischen küche hat es war wie ein
hackbraten mit rosinen und einem
gekochten obendrauf
es wird oft mit gelben reis mit samba
als die wie ein gewürz aus paprika
aussehen so wie chili kokosnuss und
bananenscheiben serviert es wird oft mit
gelben reis mit samba als die wie ein
gewürz aus paprika aussehen so wie chili
kokosnuss und bananenscheiben serviert
als ich dort war lernte ich durch einen
anderen freiwilligen eine
südafrikanische familie kennen als ich
dort war lernte ich durch einen anderen
freiwilligen eine südafrikanische
familie kennen und der kontrast der
kulturen war sehr interessant und der
kontrast der kulturen war sehr
interessant
sie haben mich zum abendessen in ihr
haus eingeladen damit ich ihre gerichte
kennen lerne
sie haben mich zum abendessen in ihr
haus eingeladen damit ich ihre gerichte
kennen lerne
dort habe ich all diese typischen
gerichte probiert dort habe ich all
diese typischen gerichte probiert und
bevor ich ins haus der gastgeberin ging
zog ich meine schuhe aus und bevor ich
ins haus der gastgeberin ging zog ich
meine schuhe aus nun du weißt dass es in
unserer kultur üblich ist das zu tun
bevor man in die häuser geht nun du
weißt dass es in unserer kultur üblich
ist das zu tun bevor man in die häuser
geht doch die gastgeberin sagte zu mir
keine sorge das musst du nicht tun du
kannst deine schuhe anbehalten
doch die gastgeberin sagte zu mir keine
sorge das musst du nicht tun du kannst
deine schuhe anbehalten
sie haben keine teller verwendet
sie haben keine teller verwendet sie
hielten es für überflüssig
also stellten sie einen großen teller in
die mitte des tisches und wir griffen
alle mit den händen nach dem essen
sie hielten es für überflüssig also
stellten sie einen großen teller in die
mitte des tisches und wir griffen alle
mit den händen nach dem essen
sehr interessant es ist schön die
möglichkeit zu haben zu reisen und
andere kulturen kennenzulernen
sehr interessant es ist schön die
möglichkeit zu haben zu reisen und
andere kulturen kennenzulernen
es war ziemlich interessant und weißt du
was mir an meiner freiwilligenarbeit am
besten gefallen hat
es war ziemlich interessant und weißt du
was mir an meiner freiwilligenarbeit am
besten gefallen hat was sag es mir bitte
was sag es mir bitte nun während ich
dort war traf ich martin einen sehr gut
aussehenden freiwilligen mit dem ich
jetzt zusammen bin nun während ich dort
war traf ich martin einen sehr gut
aussehenden freiwilligen mit dem ich
jetzt zusammen bin martin plant mich
hier in zürich zu besuchen
martin plant mich hier in zürich zu
besuchen wo kerstin wie cool ich freue
mich für dich war kerstin wie cool ich
freue mich für dich
woher kommt martin
woher kommt martin er kommt aus spanien
und es wird sein erstes mal in der
schweiz sein
er kommt aus spanien und es wird sein
erstes mal in der schweiz sein
ich hoffe es gefällt ihm ich bin sehr
aufgeregt ich hoffe es gefällt ihm
ich bin sehr aufgeregt ich möchte alle
einzelheiten dieser liebesgeschichte
wissen
ich möchte alle einzelheiten dieser
liebesgeschichte wissen natürlich werde
ich dir alles erzählen
natürlich werde ich dir alles erzählen
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video